all right let's do this one last time.
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man into the
spider verse 2 teaser trailer video
there are at least 20 different symbols
that have now been found in all those
interstitials they flashed a bunch of
different ones
everyone spotted some of the most
obvious ones last week but now we've had
a chance to dig a little deeper and
they're at least 20 symbols some things
that are even more than that so we're
doing a new Spider Man giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite version of
spider-man that you spotted during this
on the video so going down the list of
20 from top to bottom starting with
Miles Morales the reason why it's red
spray paint and all the logos even
though they're different colors and
styles are spray painted is because
miles whole thing is spray painting he
spray-painted his new symbol on ultimate
spider-man's costume when he also
colored it black he's literally wearing
the costume from Peter Parker from his
earth that at the beginning of the
movie because Aunt May gave it to him
the next shiny neon and blue one is for
spider-man 2099 we saw him during the
post credit scene creating the web wear
wrist devices that allow them to travel
the spider verse in the comics in Gwen
Stacy's spider Gwen is later seen using
one to contact Miles after the events of
the movie so it was implied that she got
one from him and at some point he'd do
the same for the other spider people so
it was kind of a given that he would
appear in some fashion during the sequel
movie the raised yellow and red one is
for Cepeda man the Japanese spider-man
from the 1970s to a TV show the
producers Phil Lord and Chris Miller
recently confirmed on Twitter that they
were going to include him in the sequel
too so he's one of the few ones that
they've actually publicly said oh we're
definitely doing him he also has a giant
mech so I'm hoping that they include
that it's much bigger than the one that
you saw penny Parker with in the first
movie the next one with a more hardcore
black symbol mixed with darker red is
for superior spider-man Otto Octavius
he's a version of Doctor Octopus whose
body is slowly failing and as he's
getting ready to he tricks
spider-man into allowing him to swap
minds and bodies so that his mind is now
in Peter Parker's body in Parker's mind
is now in his dying body the whole
premise of the character is that he
takes his new lease on life and is
determined to be a better spider-man
than Peter ever was he turned to know
much more
Tech Laden hardcore spider-man that
created Parker industries turning the
spider-man character into something of
an Iron Man esque industrialist the next
very classic looking logo is for Peter B
Parker confirming the Jay Johnson's
version is coming back which I had hoped
that he would because he was such a fun
character but since he's coming back
it's kind of hard to say how much time
will have passed on his earth and he'll
have already had his daughter made a
Parker with his version of Mary Jane
because the whole idea was that he
wanted kids now and they were getting
back together so eventually they'll
probably reference that in some way the
next bright red twist on the classic
logo is for you guessed it Ben Riley I
know a lot of you had wondered if they'd
ever do him at some point and if they
did spider pig in the first movie and
they also talked about incorporating
live-action elements like Tom Hollands
spider-man which is just nuts pretty
safe bet that any version of spider-man
no matter how weird is totally on the
table Ben Riley is just a clone of Peter
Parker created by The Jackal in 1975 in
a story titled even if I live I die
because the whole idea was is that Peter
Parker was going to have to fight Ben Riley his own clone and they were going to
off Ben Riley at least originally they
had planned to so Peter Parker would
have basically been himself they
wound up bringing the character back
during the Clone Saga in the 90s and
everyone really liked him so they just
keep bringing him back during big
spider-verse stories the big blue and
red logo is for Penny Parker confirming
this she'll be back most if not all the
original characters from the first movie
will be back in some form but because
they're introducing so many other
versions like there are 20 in this
teaser not all the characters will have
really big roles like they had in the
first film the next red logo on school
paper is for spider-ham
John Mulaney said that he had a whole
bunch of deleted scenes from the first
film just swearing while he was in
character in the booth I don't think
that they put any of that on the DVD
because he said it was - not safe for
work the white logo with pink is for
spider-gwen everyone knew she was coming
back so no big surprise they're also
developing a direct spin-off for her
character and even though Marvel is
trying to get Hailee Steinfeld is there
kate bishop hawkeye in the live-action
Hawkeye series she would still totally
continue to do all the animated
spider-verse movies no big deal going
back and forth between Sony and Marvel
and especially now that they have the
sharing arrangement of Tom Holland
relationship between companies is a lot
more amicable in Maher Sheila Ali played
the Prowler in the first spider-verse
movie and he's going to be blade in the
live-action Marvel movies going forward
the next yellow on red logo with the
moon above it as you may have guessed is
for Cyndi moon silk her origin story was
actually a retcon to the original Peter
Parker origin story by Dan Slott in the
6-1-6 comic book universe Dan Slott
wrote that when the original Peter
Parker got the spider bite the spider
fell to the ground but also bit
classmates Cindy moon's ankle before it
giving her the same spider
abilities there was a live-action
version of the character that appeared
during spider-man homecoming but did not
get the spider bite and I believe that
Sony is also trying to develop a
live-action venom spin-off movie with
her character this next one though kind
of surprised me the altered logo with
the color drained out is actually for
the 1967 original spider-man cartoon
that we saw in the post-credits scene so
not only was the post-credits scene just
a funny moment of them recreating the
pointing gif it was also meant to be a
teaser for the sequel which implies this
spider-man 2099 was actually going to
that universe to recruit him for his
team the next wire-mesh white logo is
for spider punk Hobie Brown he's the
earth 138 version of spider-man
originally operating as spider punk he's
justhe's homeless teenager who was
transformed by a spider and was
irradiated as part of president Norman
Osborn's toxic waste dumping he just
winds up becoming this punk rock
inspired spider-man leading downtrodden
people in New York City on his version
of Earth against Norman Osborn's venom
acronym venom troops I was really
surprised to see this one was for a
captain universe spider-man he was kind
of a weird character but I do remember
buying this what-if comic book when I
was a really little kid just because the
cover looked so crazy Captain universe
spider-man is part of this really weird
really complicated old story involving
the unit power he's infused with the you
know power it's something that actually
spins out of the Microverse which most
of you know in the Marvel movies right
now is actually what the quantum realm
is the reason why they can't call it the
Microverse is because Hasbro owns the
license on the Microverse in the
micronauts characters this whole captain
universe spider-man just spun out of a
a story involving them I don't know how
they're going to handle that in this
animated spider-verse series if Hasbro
still owns the license on that they'll
have to find some other way to explain
how he got the UNEP hour that I know a
lot of you are excited about this next
one the black and red on yellow logo is
none other than the bombastic bagman
version of spider-man also known as the
amazing bagman
he's the 6-1-6 version of Peter Parker
who had given the alien costume to Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four to
analyze after the events of secret Wars
so that he could just figure out what
was going on with it
but also needed to help someone because
he was left without a costume
temporarily he had to use one of the
Fantastic Four costumes and stick a bag
over his head this one that's read on
the altered shade of magenta is just for
spider-man noir who had just discovered
color during the original movie taking
the color Rubik's Cube back to his black
and white universe at the end so just
confirming that Nicolas Cage is also
coming back this bluish neon on white
one actually seems like it's for a ghost
spider which would be really cool in his
reality this version of Peter Parker had
an Uncle Ben that never he became
super rich super successful but also
wound up Breaking Bad he winds up
bringing a bunch of alternate versions
of other spider people from universes to
his absorbing their powers to make
himself more powerful until another
version of Doctor Strange and the other
heroes defeated him he went to hell
and then was infused with the spirit of
vengeance as penance for all of his
misdeeds so he's basically a Ghost Rider
version of spider-man then this one
actually might be for the 1990s animated
series spider-man this one might be
Jessica drew ultimate Spider Woman this
one seems like it's ultimate spider-man
from the spider-man unlimited animated
series in the 90s
holy moly what and then this one seems
like iron spider from the Marvel Comics
so this the 20 that I could find so far
a lot of people think that there might
even be more than that but I think
that's because when some of the logos
transition from one spider logo to
another it kind of blends together and
makes it seem like it's a different logo
so it's totally possible but the whole
idea is they're doing so many different
versions all these won't have the same
amount of screen time and some will be
probably just little Easter eggs that
are only on screen for
while so let me know in the comments if
there are any other logos that you
spotted during that teaser that you
think are going to be in the new movie and which brand new one are you most excited
about there'll be more teasers for this
next year they'll confirm more different
alternate versions as people start to
ask them more questions so as we get
more details I will do more videos about
this the really big stuff that's coming
up in the next couple of days is Rick
and Morty season 4 episode 1 starts on
Sunday and then Star Wars the
mandalorian starts on Tuesday but
that'll be a Friday show after that
first episode so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
all those videos when I post them every
one click here to watch the Sony people
talk about the sinister six spider-man
movie that they're making and every one
click here for that brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 1 video thank you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!